as you can imagine this is a very
difficult time for our family
Evan has now been wrongfully detected by
Russia for nearly six months
for doing his job as a journalist
we are still in shock every day is a day
too long
I miss him every day
Evan loves being a journalist
his passion is reporting the news and
helping people understand Russia and the
Russian people
he's always been curious about the world
and love traveling
he cares deeply about people
his reporting has kept the world
informed and we all miss reading his
stories
now what he writes is letters
we've been able to send letters back and
forth and it gives me Comfort to see how
strong he is
we are glad he's kept his sense of humor
teasing me that the prison food reminds
him of my cooking
we are all very concerned especially
since it's been so long and we want him
to come home as soon as possible
the lawyers have filed a petition asking
the United Nations to declare that
Russia's imprisonment of Heaven is wrong
and unlawful we hope this will help
bring Evan home sooner our thoughts are
with our son Evan as he endures this
difficult time in Russian prison we know
he is strong but the past several months
have been a nightmare for our family it
has also been trying for Evan's many
friends and colleagues
we hate to think of what Evan is going
through simply for doing his job
my family is encouraged to know that so
many people around the world also want
Avon released we are grateful for all
the support Evan has received
next week world leaders will gather here
to discuss many important issues
we urge all world leaders to stand with
Evan and what he represents the basic
right to a free press and freedom of
expression these rights are Bedrock
principles
of the United Nations
Evans should not be in prison in Russia
and my family should not be here today
instead we should be planning for Evan's
next visit home where he would tell us
all about his amazing travels and
experiences
we should be planning for his birthday
next month and deciding how we can
possibly match his talent for finding
the most thoughtful gifts for his family
and friends
we should be laughing together and
arguing over what he and my dad are
going to make for dinner
Evan should be doing that important work
of helping people understand matters in
the world that affect us all
instead we are here to remind the world
that Evan is innocent and journalism is
not a crime
we ask that world leaders help find a
solution to secure Evan's release
if this can happen to my brother it can
happen to any journalist trying to
report the news
we just want Evan home we miss him more
and more every day
we are thankful for everyone who is
standing with Evan and our family during
this difficult time I cannot imagine the
pain
that you are experiencing seeing your
son your brother look
locked up for simply doing his job for
reporting the truth
no family should have to watch their
loved one being used as a political Pawn
and that's exactly what President Putin
is doing Russia's actions are Beyond
cruel and they are a violation of
internationally of international law
two wrongfully detained Americans
Brittany Greiner and Trevor Reed have
now been reunited with their families
but Evan gershkovic and Paul Whalen
still languish in Russian prisons on
baseless charges
mark my word
the United States will not rest until
Evan and Paul and all wrongfully
detained Americans are home safe and
sound
it has been nearly six months since Evan
was arrested
to that end Evan's parents have
delivered a petition to the United
Nations a petition that calls on this
institution to make clear that Evan
gershwitz has been arbitrarily detained
and to push for his immediate release